secretary Rebecca long Bailey he joins
us here on the stage of News Office at
the house of parliament very good
morning to you I've been asking everyone
this this morning what was your reaction
when you heard that that vote was to be
delayed postponed
I was taken aback quite frankly I think
the ideas been mooted over the weekend
and I thought no you know she's not
gonna be that - it's not gonna leave it
till the 11th hour and then pull the
vote because she knows that she's going
to lose it but that's what happened and
you could feel the anger across
Parliament yesterday and indeed I'm sure
around the country when people thought
we were going to have an opportunity to
discuss two resumes deal and vote on it
what an opportunity to reject is what
you wanted wasn't it
well it's not just about rejecting it
it's about having the opportunity to
debate that deal and displace and convey
to the prime minister our concerns now
we haven't been given the opportunity to
do that actually said that she was going
to go away and seek assurances from the
EU on the Irish back structure hasn't
actually stated that she's going to
renegotiate any part of the withdrawal
agreement and I had questioned whether
she's going to be in a position to come
back and provide something that
Parliament can coalesce around in a few
days or a few weeks time and again
that's another problem she can't tell us
when the votes going to come back to
Parliament neither you can the Labour
Party tell us whether there's going to
be a vote of no-confidence you've been
talking about it enough over the past
couple of weeks well you know a vote of
no-confidence we take very very
seriously and we're in discussions with
various parliamentarians from all
parties within Westminster at the moment
and what we've got to do was an
opposition is assess the best time where
we know we will deliver a successful
outcome on that vote of no-confidence a
little bit of parliamentary drama and it
might make people feel better but if we
don't win that vote of no-confidence it
would have been completely pointless and
we need to make sure that we do it at
the right time yeah but it strikes me as
a little bit rich for you to criticize
the Prime Minister for delaying of what
cuz she knows that she can win it and
then doing exactly the same yourselves
when it comes to a vote of no-confidence
you can't win it right now which is why
you're not having it right now well no
what we've said all along is that
Theresa May has known for some time that
she's not going to get support from
Parliament on this deal we've stated
what our concerns are we're sure many
people within her own party have stated
what those concerns were and she's
failed to act on that for over two weeks
now she's trying to push through this
deal at all cost she's been telling
leavers that it's vote for her deal or
she's telling remainders that we either
vote for her deal or we leave the EU so
what is it we're nobody sure and at the
same time that all of this drama is
unfolding our economy suffers our
business is based on suits and saying
it's just not an ideal situation to be
in but in terms of what the Labour Party
the official opposition is going to do
next
there's no votes of no confidence
there's not going to be a general
election means what do you guys do just
twiddle your thumbs to cross there's not
going to be a vote of no-confidence I
was very clear in what I said earlier
talk to yourself was that we need to
assess the time at which we think such a
vote would be successful I think it
would be remixed and a bit you know
naive of me to state clearly today that
you know on Tuesday at 3 o'clock we're
going to issue a motion no but I think
that would be very year but very
unnecessary for us to do that but we are
working with all the parties across
Parliament to assess the best time I
mean again we return to the same
question what on earth
suggest to you that the Labour Party if
there was the opportunity present
opportunity given to you what possible
chances that the Labour Party could get
a better deal we have a different set of
priorities we've set out that we want a
permanent customs union with a right for
Britain to have a say in future trade
deals that would have dealt with the
Irish backstop situation we say that we
want a strong single market deal that
you know puts our economy and jobs first
we've stated quite clearly that we don't
want to have to see any regression in
workers rights environmental protections
made there do you honestly think that
labor members who voted to leave the
European Union see continued single mark
and customers union as brexit it's not
continued single market customs union
it's a new customs union deal and a new
single market deals there'll be a free
trade agreement if you like there gave
us access to the single market that's
very different from being a member of
the single market which we won't really
swim in there because we know it's bit
it's not a country mile away from it
though isn't it
well any free trade deal that we have
with the European Union is going to have
to provide some form of access to the
single market and you know it's bad that
politicians aren't being clear about
that you know from whichever position
they come from whether it's hard brexit
or otherwise and that's what we want to
very clear we need to have a good single
market relationship and that's what we
want to be a crook so as the the deal
that we seek to reach